Okay guys, we're gonna be getting into March 2025.
For now.
London's fine, seven till you need to be brought back an hour.
Let's go forward an hour.
Cool. Okay guys, so March. Let's kind of get through this again, apologies if
there's
any issues already or anything. I am still doing them with the cold at the
moment.
So let's kind of just pick up where we left off lower prices.
This became a liquidation but was confirmed upon the break of this.
Cool, let me change my colors. Why are my colors like that?
Okay, so I'm looking for longs.
I'm probably from this region in here.
That's what we have from a news perspective today.
We have in Europe we have four years worth of GDP growth, government budget,
inflation rate,
so that could be a good be aggressive. Let's see.
So, I'm going to be making a video about how we're going to be doing this.
Okay, no tag.
You can see that that's actually quite a rare occurrence where we don't
actually get tagged in.
We do typically get tagged in some positions. Let's move over to New York.
So, we get in New York. We're probably not going to get any type of pullback.
Not tradable for me. Yeah, not really much. We can do about that.
But we can continue the directional trend.
For this day, which is March the 4th, we have no news.
And New York, okay, we'll enter into an area of interest here.
Technically, it's 9th,
and that's sort of the session over.
Really nice liquidation into this previous level. Really, really nice.
Okay, we're continuing higher here.
For me, I don't really like this. Obviously, an Asia session low is just not.
Which doesn't really work for me. Because he is really, really aggressive price
delivery and just
unable to really capture any of the momentum, unfortunately.
Okay, I'm unable to catch any of the momentum on that.
Um, Tuesday, wait, 6th, deposit facility rate. It's in New York session.
I'm not going to get any of the momentum on that. I'm not going to get any of
the momentum on that.
Okay, so I'm going to go ahead and get some of the momentum on that.
Okay, so I'm going to take a little bit of the momentum on that.
And I'm going to take a little bit of the momentum on that.
And then I'm going to take a little bit of the momentum on that.
So I'm fortunate because I think this is a really nice setup.
But the M1 wasn't great structurally.
Yeah, like I said, you can play with things as well, like flagging things for
review.
And then give in context of what it is that you want to review.
So this is the 7th of March now.
So there we have NFP.
So we're a bearish.
And now I'm bullish again.
That's going to be that entire day.
And the rest of it done.
So that was NFP, not huge.
Yeah, not huge upset.
So no break through that price lag.
We are looking for longs.
It's a tenth balance of trade at three.
It's already finished.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's no injury.
Why is it until six?
Why is it until three months attempt?
Yeah. So, um,
clocks change March the 9th, I think it is.
Which means everything goes back an hour.
So this now becomes 11 till
two midnight till four six tonight.
And this will be until November.
Okay.
No news.
Very unorthodox one minute structure.
We would still be looking belongs.
No news.
Probably not going to get a retracement.
Yeah, not properly.
No trade there.
Continue bullish.
Sometimes it can be really frustrating when you
when you're like clear on directional bias,
but you still just can't find a way in.
, I remember this price action.
Oh, this is when I longed.
We took longs here.
After this break from here, it was discretionary,
but perfect context.
Because the M1 high was all the way up here.
By which time it was already too late.
And then New York session comes out.
And I'm pretty sure we end up trading below this low.
But I know what we're looking for.
I'm pretty sure that's why we're looking for it.
So, we're looking for a little bit more.
We're looking for a little bit more.
And that is inflationary.
Yeah.
It's technically tradable, but with equal lows across here,
and the fact that just straight from CPI,
not CPI, sorry,
inflation rate was literally five minutes ago.
This here is the biggest one.
Oh, that's kind of...
So, that's actually a liquidation.
So, it's not an actual break.
And that's an actual break.
So, now structure is actually bearish.
So, we'll be looking for shorts.
That means this is not a swing hard.
Now, we have PPI.
It's a no bit of cool.
Still bearish.
I have a mesh again, a 10.
So, we're looking for a little bit more.
So, I'm looking for a little bit more.
The M1 structure is technically bullish.
It is frustrating but objective.
We're still looking for a little bit more.
Now, we're going to break out but it's already too late.
Still technically bearish but in this type of scenario,
I don't really see the purpose of running an agent high.
There's no context.
I'm going to say it won't happen but there's no context
to run an agent high and name with us.
Okay, not to say it won't happen, just no context.
And off she goes.
Now, a bullish.
I think we've taken a single trade in March.
That's just purely objective.
Tuesdays, 16th?
I think we have building permits which is not that big of a deal.
We're going to long from here.
Generally still long from below that low.
Haven't had a one minute shift yet.
That would be, I don't know what it...
And nope.
Okay.
So we're technically looking for...
...longs pretty much anywhere above this low.
It's a bit annoying when we get in these large M15 structure ranges,
to be honest with you.
And you're basically just become kind of fixed on the bias.
Like even now, still technically bullish.
Although I'm interpreting this order flow is obviously bearish.
[silence]
No trade again.
And none of this is shifts.
[silence]
Pretty much just looking at this cluster.
I mean, technically, so you can, I'd say, prefer to be up here.
[silence]
Okay, your shifted bearish.
No news.
I remember this price section as well.
There's not a lower time frame confirmation.
Even though we got involved in shorts, it still wasn't.
A lot of time frame confirmation would have been like...
[silence]
Tele confirmation, but price just doesn't give the return.
At least we're in a better trading range.
[silence]
This becomes swing high.
Oh, I probably shouldn't be in this position.
[silence]
I should have checked that sooner.
4.30. Why is it 4.30?
[silence]
H-carb is never usually 4.30, but today it's 4.30, and the problem is,
I've been tagged into a trader for the Honestly with H-carb there probably
shouldn't be in.
It's like tagged into the trades 30 minutes before, or it doesn't give you
enough time to do anything.
[silence]
Special slipage and stuff as well, like I'm gonna just back it up and remove
this order.
[silence]
So, nothing crazy.
Nothing crazy to be honest.
[silence]
It's a H-carb manufacturing PMI flash,
which is different to the usual H-carb, but yeah.
See we can do it in New York.
We could show it from this point of interest, a little bit of an internal shift
here.
[silence]
Do you know what the market structure is like though?
So we're technically bearish, highs up here, lows down here, could do internal,
could do internal, but it's not really following the plan,
considering external is only down here. Let's see.
That's external breach.
[silence]
No news, 8.15, let's see.
And that's that done.
And quite a frustrating amounts, given the fact that
you had a good read-on price a bunch of times, but just not been up to the
execution.
Many times we've seen price run to target without tagging us.
I don't like this.
So, Asia High has been ran.
[silence]
And we're still stuck.
It's M1 range.
Even internal.
Is this law?
Okay, honestly nothing we can really do about it.
Definitely looks like decent price action, but
not really much we can do about that.
Now the M1 has only just shifted bullish from here.
Some of the M1's bullish, we're looking for shorts, so we can't even trade that
.
Even though, in my opinion, I like this price action.
Okay, now we could be looking again a short.
No, I'm too late, I believe, right?
We may get tagged on that 10am candle.
Let's see, we have a point of interest.
That's obviously our confirmation.
Point of interest, I'm already obviously looking at just this cluster.
Pretty much this value up.
So, if anything above this value up to this high, that's my cluster.
It's just a case of a little bit of a range initiation,
a little bit of a range initiation,
a negation, a little bit of a range initiation.
This is the most relevant cluster of orders.
M5 is the same.
M15 is the same.
M3 is the same.
M2 is the same.
M1 is the same.
And then that tags in on the 10am candle, literally.
That's pretty much it's breaking.
There's nothing left to be mitigated there.
That's mitigation.
And this is Fiverr.
M3 is the same.
M6 is the same.
One second, because I don't want to miss
trades just because we are in a trade.
So, we would be looking for shorts this day.
London sweeps Asia, there's no trade there, but then the law session.
The sweeps, London, the law session sweeps London.
The law session gives this.
So, I wanted to see basically a continuation from New York,
if it was a trader.
That would be New York continuation.
And then we'd need to see.
The mitigation.
It's cluster.
A lot of liquidity at these lows.
I left price on being able to make it, but
that would essentially be it.
That's really why that process, if you're wondering why I'm rewinding it,
it's because we have durable goods always at 8th day.
So, we don't know the outcome of that,
which was nothing objectively.
But we didn't know that it was going to be nothing.
It's a little bit unorthodox, but
don't worry about it.
Then that's.
I'm not going to play around with it.
We'll take that.
That's the second position of this short closed.
Let's keep moving forward.
This one was a difficult one, like durable goods.
Again, I'm not really sure if it's something that really moves price, but yeah.
Cool.
So, I have a swing high now, which is up here.
Now, we have a new swing high, which is here.
And now, to deliver bullish.
28th of May, Friday.
Personal income, personal spending, core PCA, and inflation rate, you and your
preliminary.
Cool. We can look at longs.
Yeah, we're going to have one of those M1 storage ranges in our way.
Whether M1 is actually bullish.
And to break this law, which is annoying, but it's what it is.
Damn one is bullish. Well, I mean, technically, we are looking for longs.
In a point of interest, we go internal.
But for internal, it would have to be design.
Cool.
That would give us
a reason to enter.
Probably get rid of our stops there.
And this is 315.
We do have inflation rate coming out in both living us.
Let's take a look at the same one structure, shall we?
Let's see.
What happens to inflation, right?
I can imagine it being heavily effective.
That's inflation rate.
Not really aggressive at all.
And that's also consumer confidence.
That's all news done.
We can have a shift now.
Wait, that's the actual M1 law.
That's why.
Okay, so now M1 is actually bearish.
Probably makes for a better trade to be honest with you,
because anything else would have been discretionary.
We didn't take that trade because we had inflation rate you and you.
We have 345.
We have personal income and stuff at 8th so I don't want to trade before that.
And that is personal income, etc.
What's the risk to reward like?
There's no other news after this.
We're more than like 15 minutes done as well.
And that's pretty much that.
That's 10.
So we'll remove that.
Honestly debatable, but probably just don't think I would have.
I think I already missed.
Tried to end a late.
The actual change of character comes here,
at which point then I could place my entry.
But still would have placed my entry here.
Very much likely placed my entry here.
Instead of here, here would have been a perfect tag.
M5, there you go.
Still the rest of the reward is in great as well.
Just here specifically.
Would have been exactly one to five.
What was it normally?
And a five point zone.
This is a little bit subjective because it could generally depend on the
situation.
Like if we pull price back.
At this point.
It's 840.
The news didn't really have that much of an impact.
That's the change of character.
At that point you can kind of look at placing your entry.
You have obviously the fair value gap here.
You have fair value gap entry here.
You could do last cluster.
Which is really this here.
And that would take your entry here.
You could do this last sell to buy range.
Which would take your entry also to the fair value gap.
None of them are right or wrong.
They're just different.
But then you also want to overlay contextually.
To your profit target.
What do I mean by that?
You'll see me do this all the time.
Which is where for example.
Let's say the first M5 value gap here.
Is here.
So let's say I tried the entry.
Gonna put my stuff at this low here.
Let's say I put that as my entry.
And then I look at my kind of end goal.
And I see it as a one to four.
Now I have a choice.
Either I make my stop loss come higher.
I make my entry come lower.
Or I make my T profit go higher.
That's it.
I have a choice to make.
Now I need to make that choice.
In context to the entire situation.
In this example stop loss going higher.
Does it make sense?
And target going higher.
Always could make sense.
But we always want to look here first.
Because this is where we have the most control over the outcome.
So.
If we come in here now and you go okay.
Well this entire fair value gap is.
Is broken right or it's closed.
Sorry not broken.
Which doesn't work.
Then you have two other options.
You have this option.
Right.
Which is the final sell.
To buy.
Or you have.
This option.
Right.
Which is also kind of the final software.
This gives 5.4.
This gives 4.8.
You need one to five.
And so even just.
Literally adjusting your position to make it.
Here.
One to five.
You'll see me do that often.
I'm not going to change the outcome.
I don't even know if that tags even whenever one to five.
It doesn't.
So it doesn't change the outcome.
But it's good opportunity to kind of.
Teach.
Something that you'll see me do often times.
Which is like.
Contextual.
Contextualize the segments of my.
Of my entry and stuff.
Because sometimes you might want to like.
Why why use the favor you got here.
But here you use the order block.
And why why the inverter I got here.
And you could have used the order block.
It's because like.
I'm contextualizing price action.
Always.
That's where a little bit of subjectivity comes in.
This is like 90% objective.
And then there's 20% subjectivity.
And then price kind of steam all through that.
Could have been a great trade again.
March was really just annoying.
I see here.
If we go to London.
It's the final day of March.
Let's trade this and then.
Then I'll explain it.
Yeah.
Let's go New York before I talk too soon.
Inflation mate.
Hires are up here.
And now we're technically shift bearish.
And I don't know where the trade from.
Yeah.
Cool.
That's March.
Done.
Now we move into April.
Really frustrating months.
In terms of like just purely following the playbook.
We're still.
Our win rate is a little bit higher.
Not many trades at all.
Let's go into here.
Let's make sure we're running here today.
Increase win rate.
I think it even increased average win to loss.
But the reason that's frustrating is not because of the outcome.
Obviously you can see that we're still.
.
You.
Doesn't want trade.
.
Okay.
I was.
I was confused as to what it was trying to say.
Like I was really hoping that it wasn't going to tell me that these are two
individual trades.
Because here it looked like three trades have been taken.
And I'm thinking there's no way.
That the win rate is.
33% 35% and it's counting all of the partials as two trades three trades like
there's just no way.
But it's just the interface.
So this is it says one trade one trade one trade one trades with three trades,
but it's actually.
Two trades.
Thank God for that.
So yeah, you can see here what I mean like marches are really frustrating month
.
That was profitable, right?
We've netted, you know, 5.8%.
It's in theory a great month.
And not only was it at 5.8%.
It's like just two trades were taken to six.
So seven 6.85 probably factor 66% day win rate.
Right.
Almost seven times average winter loss ratio, but only two trades were taken.
That also sums up everything you need to understand.
Like so many people tried to force trades or think that more is going to make
more.
Not necessarily.
Like if you had a million dollars in assets in the management, which is very
easy with a
prop firm like an apex, for example, a very easy to get a million in management
of futures.
And you take two trades and you made $58,000 in what in that month.
And you took two trades, right?
Don't assume that more is more.
But what's annoying here is the price action was really clean in some regards.
Like super clean in some regards, but we still didn't get executed on a lot of
trades.
So there's a annoying price action, but I need to actually go back because
that Zella school is inaccurate.
Okay.
Oh, who remembers this then?
I'm going to go back to the next one.
So, I'm going to go back to the next one.
Make sure that you're filling your data, because
you don't want to ruin your, yeah, don't have a good day.
So that takes us to
74, and we were looking at just March.
There we go. There's still low consistency.
I'm going to go back to the next one.
Just make sure the last
trades have been tucked properly.
Okay. Okay, now we're going to move over into April.